after two months of unprecedented
increases
the us unemployment rate took a
surprising turn in may
it went down this dip was a hopeful sign
that the economy might be bouncing back
from coronavirus lockdowns
but that dip wasn't universal black
unemployment ticked upwards
it declined in june but not at the same
rate as unemployment overall
this follows a decade where the
unemployment gap between white and black
workers has been narrowing
but the recent unemployment figures
reveal the financial fragility that has
persisted for many black workers since
the last recession
fragility that has left them poised for
a difficult recovery
this time around
historically recessions or periods of
high unemployment have been worse for
black americans
if you look back 50 years you can see
that this isn't the first time
black workers have faced these levels of
joblessness
double-digit unemployment is actually
nothing sort of unfamiliar for
african-americans so
while everyone was kind of shocked about
how high unemployment spiked when the
pandemic hit
for african-americans this is nothing
new actually when it came to the 2008
financial crisis
all racial groups saw their wealth
devastated but wealth for black
households was much slower to recover
a few factors contributed to this
difference among them was that black
workers were more likely to have
temporary jobs during the recovery
this occurred for a couple of reasons so
for instance african americans are
overrepresented in the criminal justice
system and we know that having a
criminal background
for instance can be an impediment to
employment we also know that african
americans
are more likely to be represented in
temporary jobs
and service sector jobs the kind of jobs
that can have sort of less stability
more turnover government data shows that
in 2018
white workers had on average 17 months
more tenure at their jobs than black
workers
also the differences for black and white
workers and median household income
and wages have largely remained
unchanged for decades
so some of the economists that i've been
speaking to as i've been reporting on
black unemployment
points out that although african
americans were making gains in the labor
market
as the expansion continued that really
sort of masked
some of the lingering inequalities that
african americans
are dealing with in terms of wealth and
wealth is what we typically think of
as providing a cushion to people when
there is an economic downturn
in 2016 the median black household had
less than 18 thousand dollars in net
worth
compared with a hundred and seventy one
thousand dollars for white households
and in the fourth quarter of 2019 black
home ownership was down four percentage
points from 2007.
while white homeownership had almost
regained its pre-recession level
but as the economic expansion continued
there were signs that black workers were
finally beginning to benefit
and in 2018 wages for black workers
began to increase
and by february 2020 the black
unemployment rate was near record lows
then the coronavirus pandemic hit
by april black unemployment had surged
to 16.7 percent
compared to 14.7 percent overall for
black workers who kept their jobs many
were in industries that put them at risk
these employees made up a higher
percentage of frontline workers
in industries like public transit and
healthcare than their share of workers
overall
so economists and other experts have
really been pointing out that it has
been
a one-two punch for the african-american
community first on the health front
because african americans has
have suffered a disproportionate number
of deaths from coven 19
and so some economists are kind of
sounding the alarm that the recovery
could not be even and could actually lag
for african americans
but economists say the 2 trillion
stimulus package and paycheck protection
program
may be helpful in lowering black
unemployment although maybe not to
pre-pandemic levels
anytime soon there are some concerns
though
that some of the aid may not be reaching
african-american communities so for
instance when the paycheck protection
program
first rolled out a lot of african
american small businesses were reporting
not being able to access it
and protests over the killing of george
floyd might lead to more ideas and
movement on solving some long-standing
disparities
a lot of the the workers and business
owners that we talked to also
said perhaps now is the time to really
have
conversations about policies that will
address these long-standing inequalities
in wealth and health that
african-americans
have experienced and that this
coronavirus pandemic really
exposed once again the economic
disparities felt by black workers are
long-standing
and interconnected and as the last
recovery showed
may take a long time to show signs of
improvement